est-ce que vous pensez qu'avec la
canicule l'été dernier vous avez perdu
une grande partie de votre clientèle non
je ne crois pas je l'avais déjà
renouvelé
bonsoir Charles Aznavour très heureux de
vous avoir sur le plateau de Tout le
monde en parle merci ça va Bonne Année
2004 vous avez fait vous avez fait quoi
pour les fêtes
c'est pas important pour moi non non
pendant des années les fêtes c'était une
matinée de plus oui quand c'était pas
deux avec le début
du travail ça veut dire une
représentation pas une grasse matinée
une matinée en plus à planter une
matinée une matinée de music hall où
vous voulez dire un spectacle en plus
peut-être les gens n'avaient pas compris
chez eux Charles
est-ce que est-ce que vous avez pris des
bonnes résolutions pour l'année 2004 je
vais travailler ah ouais d'accord c'est
la meilleure des résolutions alors vous
sortez un nouvel album c'est Capitole
email qui s'appelle The voyage donc 12
chansons sur vos sujets favoris la
jeunesse la société l'amour la nostalgie
qui s'appelle la critique vous dites on
a beau dire au fond que l'on sent contre
fou elle vous détruit le moral et vous
en fout un coup qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez mais j'en pense que j'en pense
c'est que vous qui avez jamais répondu
c'est-à-dire vous avez jamais abordé le
problème de la critique vous avez jamais
répondu ni par téléphone ni par courrier
vous avez toujours ignoré les critiques
et Dieu sait si vous en avez eu je
trouve ça formidable que un jour comme
ça vous en parliez en disant en plus la
vérité c'est-à-dire non on s'en fout
mais en fait ça nous fait du mal quoi
puis c'est amusant de le faire
aujourd'hui parce que vous êtes une
vache sacrée aujourd'hui
personne veuillère du mal de vous
Charles c'est sûr alors c'est un peu
peut-être mais j'avais envie de le faire
non c'est bien parce que c'est pas amer
en plus vous dites oui c'est vrai la
critique on l'écoute quelque part
c'est quand vous avez fait l'Olympia en
il y avait un journaliste qui avait
écrit pourquoi ne pas chanter avec une
jambe de bois c'est vraiment méchant
donc là vous avez exigé un droit de
réponse c'est la seule fois d'ailleurs
sur Radio Luxembourg vous aviez droit à
3 minutes finalement vous êtes resté 9
minutes je vous en pouviez plus là oui
oui d'autant plus je venais d'avoir un
accident alors le genre de bois j'aurais
pu la voir mais vous avez beaucoup
enduré quand même au début avec votre
physique votre voix vos chansons j'avais
tout contre moi c'est vrai la voix les
chansons disaient que c'était pas
c'était pas
populaire aujourd'hui c'est le
commercial j'ai droit à tout un jour au
Crazy Horse et vous entendez quelqu'un
qui dit j'ai jamais entendu rien de plus
con il était devant moi j'avais envie de
lui donner un coup de pied dans la
figure mais c'est pas dans mes habitudes
il y a un journal qui avait écrit
maintenant on laisse chanter les
handicapés
maintenant on lit plus ça dans les
critiques quand même
les choses ont évolué
alors Charles Aznavour le 22 mai 2004
vous fêterez vos 80 ans sur la scène du
Palais des Congrès ce sera
incroyable tu réussirais même avoir 80
ans
à part l'audition et il est nickel
alors donc le 22 mai 2004 donc vous
aurez 80 ans sur scène ce sera la
dernière de vos représentations qui
commencent le 16 avril je le dis je le
dis à tout le monde parce qu'attention
lui sur scène c'est 30 chansons c'est ça
non ah oui 30 ah ouais pas de rappel pas
de rappel mais 30 chansons
vous êtes très très pudique vous êtes
absolument ininterviewables parce que
c'est intéressant
dans les journaux en question je n'y
suis jamais on a fait un petit sondage
sur vous Charles Aznavour 67% des
Français pensent que vous avez une
tortue trois Canaries une chatte par
exemple c'est complètement con je les ai
parlé en tout cas 13% des Français
pensent que vous êtes chauffeur de taxi
à
comme quoi vous devriez quand même
beaucoup plus
4% des Français trouvent que vous leur
faites penser à quelqu'un sans qu'il
puisse retrouver le nom
et alors là 91% des Français pensent que
vous portez des talonnettes
non j'ai failli avant vous avez pas
besoin là
voilà
merci
j'ai ciré les pompes à l'idée et j'ai
mis son soulier à Charles
[Applaudissements]
qui vous connaissent mal c'est pas une
perruque vous avez fait des
implants
ça vachement bien marché chez vous mais
la terre est bonne si vous avez les
cheveux un petit peu long en ce moment
parce que vous allez faire un rôle c'est
pas du tout pour faire le c'est pas cool
votre nouveau-né a été offert par piece
vous racontez ça dans votre
autobiographie le temps des avants paru
chez Flammarion et avec Greco c'est vrai
que vous avez été les premiers moi je me
souviens à vous faire refaire le nez en
en parlait à la maison c'est un
événement aujourd'hui tout le monde se
fait refaire le nez non il a pas fait
non vous étiez les premiers avec Greco
non si c'était assez scandaleux à
l'époque quand même oh bah moi on l'a
pas su parce que j'étais inconnu donc on
a fait les cheveux on a fait le nez et
là le plus terrible faisons la [ __ ]
avant la 10 avant ce que tu sais pas ce
que tu sais pas c'est que quand il était
petit Charles Aznavour avait les jambes
arquées oui déficience
j'avais les jambes Louis XII voilà Louis
XII en vacances c'est tragique
d'ailleurs à Berck
plage magnifique
vous allez survécu à tout vous allez
survécu à la critique on l'a vu vous
êtes survécu à la guerre parce que c'est
vrai pendant la guerre quand je vais
partir on va dire que j'ai survécu à
distance
vous étiez souvent pendant l'occupation
je disais souvent amené à la commande en
tour vous prenez pour un petit jeu et
vous étiez emmené à la commande en tour
je pensais pas pour un Français pur sang
45 c'est trop tard alors vous avez
survécu d'abord à cause de ça ensuite
vos parents étaient sympathisants
communistes ils étaient amis avec
Manouchian de FTP molle la fiche rouge
ça c'était il venait chez vous mais nous
chiant il venait vous apprenez les
échecs oui venez chez nous et puis ça sa
femme a été cachée chez nous ensuite
c'est les amis
de longtemps auparavant donc survécu à
la commande en tour survécu à la
fréquentation de increvable non mais
c'est vrai
alors vous quittez l'école à l'âge de 10
ans et demi et à 15 ans en fait du
marché noir pour nourrir votre famille
parce que votre père était engagé
courageusement et là vous vendez du
chocolat des charcuteries et des bas
pour femme oui
allemande
de Paris mais avec ma petite sacoche
comme ça et puis je proposais mes bas
aux Allemands qui voulaient absolument
en acheter dans les acheter je me
souviens exactement depuis je vendais
tout c'est toujours 20 marques
d'occupation mais je partais vite parce
que dès qu'on pensait la main dedans sa
filet alors un jour il y a un riche
arménien qui décide de faire une bourse
comme ça pour aider des petits Arméniens
les enfants démunis vous vous retrouvez
dans une école pour apprendre la TSF
enfin ça vous ennuie énormément
évidemment le centrale de TSF rue de la
lune voilà j'ai eu de la Lune vous
emmerdez vous séchez les cours pour
aller
de cinéma l'après-midi au music-haut le
soir
j'anticipe des cours de comédie il était
dans L'assassin habite au 21 c'est ce
que j'allais dire je t'adore là c'est
exactement ce que je suis moi-même je
fais des films
[Applaudissements]
et alors en 1941 vous rencontrez Pierre
Roche et vous faites un duo qui
s'appelle roche et Aznavour au départ
c'était vous êtes embauché partout voilà
c'était dans des boîtes de nuit
et en 45 votre première chanson j'ai vu
est interprété par par Georges Gilbert
et leur montant la refusé cette chanson
ça c'est incroyable à la fin c'est
intéressant ça quand même vous êtes un
jeune auteur compositeur de chansons
vous êtes en face d'Yves Montand qui est
quand même déjà une star il vous dit moi
je suis d'accord pour chanter ta chanson
si à la fin il meurt vous dites non non
mais j'ai même eu des chanteurs très
connus qui voulaient consigner les
chansons je dis non j'aime mieux pas
donner la moitié d'une œuvre à quelqu'un
qui n'a pas travaillé dessus comme je
n'ai jamais parce que je changeais une
ligne ou une phrase dans une chanson
d'un camarade je n'ai jamais dit je
signe avec toi ça je trouve ça
pas joli vous êtes bien ouais la classe
la classe c'est la classe et et montant
a refusé alors ça c'est encore pire que
tout je me voyais déjà en disant il y a
jamais une chanson sur le métier qui a
marché c'est
fouable parce que la plupart des gens
pensaient la même chose alors en 1946
Francis Blanche vous présente Edith Piaf
c'était dans une émission de Francis
Blanche que l'on a connu Pierre mais
c'est pas lui qui nous la présenter
c'est elle qui vous a fait comme ça
comme ça elle m'a fait comme dans
sans parler anglais sans parler anglais
en lisant les textes et la tête pas de
talonnette mais la déco
vous avez peur de la marche
ça dépend des jours aujourd'hui
ça va aujourd'hui ça va très bien vous
croyez que vous aurez droit mais
funérailles nationales non non
ou alors en Arménie ah peut-être mais
j'irai pas là-bas j'ai un camion en
France
du troisième siècle ah oui pas n'importe
quoi et puis en face j'ai Jean Marchal
un peu plus loin j'ai Cécile j'ai
Marchal ah il y a du monde chez nous oui
je suis mieux que j'ai
fait construire ce qu'il fallait
d'ailleurs j'ai la folie de la
construction alors les voisins sont
sympas
national
[Musique]
c'était un petit peu difficile pour vous
puisque vous êtes mort donc vous êtes
mort comment alors je suis mort de
vieillesse
vous l'avez trouvé comment le discours
de Chirac à l'enterrement un peu
tremblotant
et quand l'équipe de la Star Academy a
chanté emmenez-moi ça vous a ému oui
surtout que c'était la nouvelle équipe
oui on les anciens n'étaient pas venus
ils avaient des béquilles
vous aimeriez qu'on dise quoi de vous
maintenant que vous êtes mort Charles
Aznavour
quoi qu'on me grandisse vous savez que
vos ventes de disques sont repartis
c'est énorme depuis que vous êtes mort
vous avez vendu 10 millions
est-ce qu'il y a des œuvres posthumes
des trucs que vous avez jamais publié en
vivant et qui vont ressortir maintenant
comme les Beatles oui oui j'ai laissé ma
voix sur des des bandes électroniques
nouvelles et ils ajouteront l'orchestre
ils voudront ajouter dessus par la suite
est-ce que vous savez qu'on va
rebaptiser rue Aznavour la rue sarrazade
ah oui oui c'est un projet c'est de la
Noël qui est toujours mer de Paris
d'ailleurs qui était sarrazade je sais
pas un violoniste espagnol un grand
violoniste je me suis renseigné
pour le reste non je me suis renseigné
c'était quoi votre dernier mot avant de
mourir Charles Aznavour je reviendrai ah
[Applaudissements]
bravo
mail les gens savaient évidemment que
vous seriez là ce soir ils envoyaient
des mails sur le site France 2 qui
s'inscrit en bas de l'écran Vincent
Torres de Toulouse dites-moi Charles
Aznavour vous avez fait Fuji aldrucker
en aparté la Star Ac il se vend pas
votre album ou quoi
non on l'a fait pour que ça se vende
ouais c'est ça d'accord Nicole guibaudet
de Boulogne-Billancourt est-ce que vous
pensez qu'avec la canicule l'été dernier
vous avez perdu une grande partie de
votre clientèle non je ne crois pas je
l'avais déjà renouvelé
j'aime quand vous faites ça bien
Stéphane Gonzalez de Strasbourg vous
avez reçu en 1974 le prix de l'artiste
pop le mieux habillé pourquoi ne pas
vous être changé depuis
là vous m'avez un peu stoppé je dirais
simplement que une fois qu'on l'a dit
c'est la plus importante après un mail
d'Hervé Bodino de Bron savez-vous qu'il
existe un remake d'un taxi pour Tobrouk
qui s'appelle un taxi pour que je te
broute
[Musique]
je voyage
le bouquin s'appelle le temps des avants
il est publié chez Flammarion
[Musique]
ah oui
et oui bons clients très bon client sur
les amours tu as raison Laurent bravo
vous revenez que ça vous revenez quand
vous voulez même si vous avez pas de
disques ou de livres à vendre vous
pouvez revenir buvincourt j'ai pas
toujours quelque chose
car des alcooliques pas anonymes
non c'est ah non c'est autre chose
ah bah oui
confrérie des cons mieux vaut être super
con que rien du tout
non on n'est pas loin non mais il y a
Marcel Julien il y a Jean Reno
on a pas une chance on n'est pas une
centaine il y a écrit Charles Aznavour
l'arménien
[Applaudissements]
et là avec la carte de bon client tout
le monde en parle vous êtes reçu partout
dans le monde entier ah c'est vous
monsieur Aznavour et pour être sûr de ne
rien rater de inarritube abonnez-vous et
mettez un pouce bleu